alright guys so we're just drop don't
make me read chicken fact so I eat
chicken oh we're gonna eat fried chicken
I love fried chicken how many days a
week to eat fried chicken like three
four white what's there not to like
about fried chicken yeah I agree it like
has like an endorphin release when I eat
fried chicken like I feel happier I had
a lot experience of fried chicken I grew
up with it um my mom cooks it my grandma
cooks it I think her grandma cooked it I
like fried chicken I mean I like chicken
in general that's why I'm in this video
it's one of the greatest song inventions
of known a man thank you
hmm what is this why are people walking
in we haven't met yet with uh they're so
cute
oh my god you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're so cute I have no words is this
what fried chicken becomes no no this is
what becomes fried chicken feathers are
gorgeous you're very pretty animals like
gold we don't don't abandon this one all
right I'm gonna take this one home goals
and futures you're gonna I would love to
and you want to kiss each other
little chicken kiss
[Music]
I am honestly kind of bummed out that
there's no chicken here this changes
nothing
the moment you walked in with these I
felt really bad it might be affecting me
it might be affecting them up there I
mean we all have purposes in life and
some of them wow I don't want to be
sitting next to power my it does make me
want to learn more about where my
chicken comes from this wood sleepy you
know it's in like the store it's like
not even an animal anymore and I this is
putting a face to it now are you getting
in endorphin rush I'm good though like
thank you no you know what no matter in
what state chickens give me a little bit
of a joy you know
[Music]